en cette saison des amours les
batraciens rejoignent leurs points de
natal pour se reproduire
seulement à gan b l'étang de la bruyère
est séparée de la forêt par une goutte
alors depuis 12 ans nicole s'occupe
d'eux à l'aide des lycéens du chef de
tremblay sur mauldre et d'autres
bénévoles elles disposent des barrières
de 140 mètres de long financé par la
commune de gan b et le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
afin d'empêcher les batraciens de se
faire écraser les arrive effectivement
de la forêt y vont longer la bassée à un
moment ils vont tomber dans le faux et
chaque matin jusqu'au mois d'avril des
bénévoles viennent ramasser les
batraciens des sceaux pour les faire
traverser en toute sécurité
si nicole a commencé seule avec son mari
et son fils au fil des années d'autres
amoureux de la nature l'ont rejointe
comme aymeric il s'est arrêté il allait
à la boulangerie se rappelle et il a dit
à l'année prochaine vous me contacter je
viendrai vous aider voilà ce n'est pas
la faute et contacté alors de alors je
note rahmane chaque batraciens et
répertoriés pour prouver l'efficacité de
la démarche
il y à 12 ans 500 animaux ont été sauvés
cette année les 6 ramasseurs espère
dépasser les 2500 127 crapauds mâles
dix neuf femelles et trois triton palmé
ce qu'il fait 149 batraciens sauvé
aujourd'hui fort de leur réussite les
bénévoles ont demandé un système plus
pérenne de bâtera co d'uc soit des
tunnels sous la route dédiée donc le pnr
tout à fait d'accord c'est que ça fait
un an quand même qu'on a déposé le
dossier contacté le pnr se dit sensible
à la démarche mais le terrain est en
complexe les études hydrographique
doivent être menées elles auront lieu
courant mars